hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we are chatting about iPhone 8
rumors because there has been a few that
came out the past couple of days and
since the last time I talked about it
also something has come out quite
recently if you are new on my channel or
if you've been here for quite a while
I've been chatting about the new Samsung
Galaxy s8 that just recently came out
and I've got a lot of you guys worried
like super worried I think getting text
emails hauls every one thing Justine
have you gone to Android I haven't gone
anywhere I'm here this is my baby this
is my child I've had a secondary Android
device for probably five or six years
this is not really new information I've
talked about it before but for some new
people or from some old people who
weren't aware of that you guys have been
a little concerned but don't worry I'm
still here this is still my first love
but I also love other things too so it's
okay it's alright now that we've got
that out of the way let's hop into some
iPhone 8 rumors and this first one it
just recently came out this schematic
was released I think let's see on
Wednesday April 26th is when my dear
friends MacRumors covered it I love you
guys so it looks like they've moved the
flash in between the two cameras and
just flipped it I have no idea what that
is it's probably I would assume
something for wireless charging so the
schematic appears to depict the interior
of an oled iphone 8 that matches many
previously leaked design schematics and
rumours which is good so that hopefully
can help us to believe that this might
be true but Apple is also testing
several different prototypes so this
could be watch this one says that
there's no your touch ID button included
in this one which was also I believe an
issue in the Samsung Galaxy phones
whether time constraints design
constraints it never actually ended up
working out which is probably why most
of the other phones like the pixel and
the Samsung decided to put the touch ID
buttons on the back because it might
just make the most sense and it's
probably the easiest to implement
because I'm sure trying to get the touch
ID buttons underneath of the screens
that save time consuming and I'm sure
there's other issues that I'm not even
we're about the window body and I
trusted you home button located on the
rear of the device so it's gonna be
interesting you see which way Apple
actually does go I feel like the most
reliable option especially in previous
phones seems to be on the back
I mean if anybody's gonna do it I feel
like Apple's gonna be the ones that is
able to sort of make that actually work
having the home button be under the
front display they're also not
mentioning much here at all about the
front of the phone which is going to be
something that I'm super interested in
because the facial recognition on the
galaxy s 8 is pretty cool I mean I just
hope my phone has turned on it's already
here it's ready will the iPhone do
facial recognition
I've also I haven't posted this video
yet but I've been testing out the
surface studio and it's been super cool
having the facial recognition I just
walk up to my computer and it turns on
all right so that's the schematic let's
see oh this actually it just came out
today Apple is once again rumored to
launch its own venmo like service
allowing iPhone users to pay friends and
family members which would completely
makes sense
I mean Apple pay is so awesome like I
absolutely love it the only problem is
it doesn't work with all credit card
companies I think it's very Bank
specific so it doesn't work with
everyone whereas venmo and PayPal and
other things like that do work pretty
seamlessly with everything unnamed Apple
payment would include major partnership
with Visa that's nice so here's a render
of what it potentially could look like
with the vertical camera although in
this mock-up it does have this little
flash over here so that would be moved
over here to match this little guy
what's this I mean this is a pretty poor
render but it also kind of gives us
another sense of what it would look like
with potentially a touch ID button on
the back I mean if Apple was smart they
would make the Apple logo touch ID
that's something I'm down with so here's
a potential render but this looks so
much like the current iPhone 7
it's I don't know the iPhone 8 will come
with a USBC to lightning cable possibly
for easier connectivity to MacBooks I
feel like the overlap of the people who
we want a USBC to lightning as opposed
to those who would just want the regular
USB to lightning I don't feel like that
overlap is very great I could be wrong
so here we have a really nice mock-up
which looks basically like if we took
the iPhone 7 plus smashed it together
with the galaxies is what we have okay I
don't know I don't know I'm not sure
what kind of mock-up is this this looks
exactly like the iPhone 7 plus with a
gradient Apple logo what are you drunk I
could have made that tell me more this
is beautiful it looks like a fat s8
that's something I want to put in my
pocket oh hello hi God yeah yes yes I
love it I love it this is this is what
we're talking about kind of a theory
button looks just I mean that looks like
garbage but I mean whatever so here we
have the potential for the fingerprint
sensor there on the back it's impossible
case info that's the one that we've just
seen here's the full screen Oh baby
this looks to be like it's edge to edge
but it doesn't look like it's curved
around the sides necessarily as much as
it is on some of the other shots or even
like the galaxy is that gold looks
disgusting what the heck is this did you
just Photoshop two holes and say here's
your camera deep black bright whites
brilliant colors scanning iris that
looks cool I'm just gonna touch ID but
it's just an all new iris scanner all
new home button I'm hoping that they can
integrate that fingerprint scanner into
the screen because that would seriously
be incredible so USBC yes sir
yes sir iPhone 8 Pro I mean I really
hope that you can use the Apple pencil
in the next moment like come on Apple
wireless charging did you just take a
an Apple TV and Photoshop but if T here
so here's some other specs that are
ruurd a variety of possible sizes five
point eight five point five a five
that's a lot that's a lot of choices
curved edge to edge OLED display with
the true tone technology home button
touch ID located on back or integrated
it and display new touch ID featuring
face or iris scanning hello wireless
charging dual lens support for Apple
pencil USBC replacing Apple's lightning
connector enhanced water resistance
which I mean because I just don't want
to talk about it
I dropped my phone in the toilet I'm an
idiot well I guess that's it I just
wanted to chat with you guys quickly
about some of the things that I have
seen and I want to get your thoughts as
always and I also just wanted to
reassure you don't worry I'm still an
Apple fan just because I'm making videos
about Samsung and no those are not
sponsored videos they are purely my
opinion they did send me the phone to
check out but I have no requirements to
do anything it was just like here's the
phone do whatever you want with it
I wanted to do a durability test but I
just feel like I end up doing durability
tests on my own just in my daily life
and I also feel really bad about just
breaking a phone on purpose cuz I do it
enough accidentally and it hurts my
heart and I feel like there's enough
youtubers out there who do destroy their
things on purpose
so that content is already there you're
a beautiful little baby I mean what's it
gonna be like having a vertical camera
yeah I probably won't even notice a
difference to be honest with you
[Music]